éditorialiste alexis poulain bonjour
alexis poulard merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france est donc acté pas
de revalorisation énorme pour le smic
cette année seulement une revalorisation
automatique
oui de toute façon le gouvernement
n'aime pas revoir à la hausse les
salaires minimums et même dans d'autres
professions qui ne sont pas forcément au
smic on préfère les primes
exceptionnelles plutôt que d'augmenter
les salaires que ce soit pour les
soignants les enseignants on a bien vu
la difficulté qu'il y avait à
revaloriser les salaires donc pour le
salaire minimum
c'est exactement la même chose l'idée
étant que plus on va augmenter les
salaires minimums pue le fric du manque
d'embauché se fait grand ce qui n'est
pas forcément vrai mais une réalité
c'est que cette crise du covin a touché
davantage les travailleurs les plus
précaires qui ont perdu davantage de
pouvoir d'achat déjà ça c'est un fait
comparé aux autres employés et s'il n'y
avait pas eu d' aide alors ce serait
plus de 17 % de baisse de salaire pour
les salaires les moins élevés donc on
voit bien qu'il ya un problème de
pouvoir d'achat qui va se faire jour de
toute façon donc il va falloir réfléchir
à quelles sont les solutions pour aider
des français qui sont payés au minimum à
ne pas tomber dans la précarité
on se rappelle que le mouvement des
gilet jaune avait pris son origine dans
ce problème du pouvoir d'achat dans
cette difficulté de boucler les fins de
mois pour les travailleurs les moins
bien payés en france et d'ailleurs c'est
moi un rapport de l'insee ce sont plus
d'un million de français qui ont basculé
dans la pauvreté depuis le début de la
crise sanitaire
ces cartes et une revalorisation du smic
actuellement va pas justement provoqué
la grogne des français
alors aujourd'hui beaucoup de sujet
provoque effectivement la grogne de
mécontentement la colère la
compréhension et c'est vrai que se dire
que ça va coûter beaucoup plus cher en
fait de ne pas aider des français qui
pourraient tomber dans la précarité et
de les maintenir avec un certain niveau
de vie c'est une externalité négative
qui va être prise en charge par la
société mais à quel coût
on voit le rôle important des banques
alimentaires pour les étudiants pour les
plus précaires
des personnes qui n'étaient jamais allés
auparavant aux restos du coeur ou à
d'autres banques alimentaires qui ont
été obligés d'y aller depuis les
confinements successifs la reprise de la
croissance qui n'est pas vu à la hausse
et l'office international du travail
l'oit et qui voit aussi une baisse des
salaires global qui va continuer à
s'accentuer
compte tenu de la faible croissance dans
les mois qui viennent donc effectivement
que va faire le gouvernement compte dans
le plan de relance de 100 milliards
d'euros qui est dédié à la relance de
l'économie
seulement 800 millions qui sont dédiées
à la lutte contre la pauvreté et la
précarité majoritairement pour aider les
banques alimentaires les associations
mais pas de robe lise ration
effectivement des salaires minimums
alors la crise coûte beaucoup énormément
mais est-ce qu'elle va encore coûter
encore longtemps et tout est la question
en fait de la reprise de l'activité et à
quel niveau alors pour le ministre de
l'économie bruno le maire il se veut
extrêmement optimiste pour lui en 2021
la france va rebondir fort je ne sais
pas ce que ça veut dire en vrai mais
c'est que l'idée que ces milliards
injectés dans les entreprises vont
permettre d'éviter certaines faillite
pas toutes mais certaines faillite et de
relancer une partie de l'activité
rapidement on peut faire de bordeaux
2008 en attendant les nombreuses
faillites avant de reprendre l'activité
reste à voir si c'est réel et puis reste
à voir quel sera l'état de l'économie au
niveau international beaucoup
d'incertitudes demeurent
même si le vaccin est là pour rassurer
les marchés les investisseurs et les
chefs d'entreprise
rien ne dit que ça va suffire pour
retrouver des niveaux d'avant la crise
qui ne reviendront peut-être pas avant
2022 2023
alexis pour la remercier d'avoir répondu
à nos questions vous rappelle que vous
êtes éditorialiste à merci